he's Michael Vick I guess he's now the
former NFL quarterback Michael Vick
after 13 seasons are you officially
retired Mike yes I'm officially retired
and happy and happy even if you got a
phone call right now let's say you got a
phone call next week
you're officially retired oh man that
would be that would be tough time
because I still love the game of
football so it would definitely be
something that I would think about and
consider but I had ankle surgery in
March and that may slow me down a little
bit and I'm slowly but surely recovering
an 80% right now so that would also take
I'll have to take that into account
did you have too much natural talent
yeah I think so to a point where it hurt
me in terms of the way prepared
sometimes I'm always believing in my
natural ability but you know I use that
as an example in talking to kids if you
feel like and know that you have too
much ability then always continue to
maximize the compound or that you know
problem that is not so much of a problem
it's a good thing and you know when you
do that you get more out of yourself you
get the best out of your abilities and
that's just taking advantage of your
god-given gifts and not taking it for
granted who do you consider the greatest
quarterback of all time Tom Brady the
greatest quarterback of all the time I
don't think what he's done for the game
of football but I would be accomplished
again because it's a tough game and you
know it's very few to come around like
Tom here and then you know to see the
things that he's done you know Ben and
late round draft pick goes to show that
anybody can get it done any in any given
time any given day um regardless of what
realm you're drafted in Tom's Testament
the hard work is the reason why he's had
so much affair could you bend that kind
of quarterback I think I could have been
a quarterback that could have
just a lot more obviously he's going to
game of football is a lot it's tons of
games that you wish you can stack terms
of plays touchdowns penalties that
affected so many games that I played in
but I tell you you know in terms of you
know what I've been able to accomplish
in my career yes there's always a
feeling that you could have had more but
I think the greatest thing I took away
from the game of football is my love
because I realized how much you know
emotions went into the game where we
lost I found out how much I really and
truly loved the game when we didn't win
what was the highlight if I said to
somebody who never saw you play watch
this and you understand Michael Vick
what would it be you know so many plays
I think you know maybe the play against
Minnesota and on my second year or I
think one of the play against I figured
some saying his name correctly bars or
bigger Billy yeah in Green Bay in a
playoff game of 2002 when he had me on
the sidelines I just push them along man
to the right directly into the sidelines
and was able to scramble to make a great
play but the pure will that I had at the
time and my desire to just be great was
unbelievable at that time and I could
always look back and say I appreciate
that part of my game of my career
do you ever apologize to a defensive
player yeah I think I have on multiple
occasions there were times where there
were times where I dominated the game so
much that I started to feel bad about
what I was doing you know it was an
eerie feeling but yeah I was able to it
was it was fun at the same time I'm like
fan of myself man you're doing too much
to scale back a little bit and I said
that when I was oh wait you held back
because you're embarrassing people so
badly grabbed yeah but we was probably
up by 2030 so it was it was Marik so it
was reasoning for it we're talking to
Michael Vick
formally retired spent 13 seasons in the
NFL explain the Colin Kaepernick
comments and then it feels like you
walked him back a little bit on he
should cut his hair so just to get it
out get the record straight
what were you saying about Colin
Kaepernick and what he should do when I
get in and say what I said I should have
never said um you know I think it was
taken out of context I'm in released and
regards to what I was you know trying to
convey
but you know I only want to help
Kaepernick and now I'm not a general
manager I'm not the guy that makes the
decisions on getting them fine and I'm
truly sorry for what I said I think I
should have used a better choice of
words you know obviously we all know
after has nothing that don't have being
signed and I was you know trying to save
relate that message you know it was just
more so about you know how to have at
the end of the day and you know and all
my interviews all I have ever tried to
do was help him in sort of positive and
you know spoke about the things that I
think were the issues and reasoning why
he he probably hasn't been signed but
you know was always up in this thing and
believing that he will be at some point
if you look at all my you listen to all
my interviews on look at him I just did
one previously last Friday in Virginia
you know it was always kind of lift them
I applaud him for what he's trying to do
and you know but I'm not a general
language at the end of the day did you
change your presentation when you came
out of prison to get back into the NFL
no not to get back into the NFL I think
it was more soaking my personal my
parent symbol and what I really wanted
and you know in speaking to kids trying
to help kids looking like differently I
didn't want to you know them to look at
me as you know somebody who they really
can't look up to and I think you're
started with my parents and you know the
message that I was trying to convey at
the time and um you know being safe and
being genuine and being honest you know
so I always try to be honest with myself
and you know like I said I stand in the
world of my own and because I've been
through things that people haven't
haven't been through
doesn't make me any different from
anybody else but this experiences that I
can you know fall back on it and help me
you know make decisions on a day-to-day
basis
Oh Jay Simpson had a chance to be
paroled today do you remember what that
was like did you have a parole hearing
no well my situation was you know it was
cutting the ride and we stick out
straight to the point we just got it out
the way but now no parole hearing and
hey look I don't know what's gonna
happen I'll be one of the ones watching
what was that like though that that day
when you know that you're getting out
what's that feeling like when all of a
sudden they open it opened the door
opened the gate you wake up that morning
do you remember what that was like
that's our only unexplainable feeling
because when you walk that walk that
life for so long it's sad to say that
you kind of adjust to it and you tend to
call that home really you know so to
speak so when you're leaving you're
leaving a lot of people that you know
you've been around every day and you
know created friendships within or
created ideas and concepts and whether
they gonna come true or not you know
it's a belief and I I think I'm you know
you're more so happy that you will come
home and carry out those plans but you
leave a lot of people behind who you
know really Hill was hoping don't have
it so you know it's twofold and I have a
lot of respect for little guys in the
prison system because you know they're
no smart guys but you know you just need
an opportunity they just need a chance
and you know if you provide that man and
if they get it then I think a lot of
them you know make sure when we went to
that prison in Tampa with Tony Dungy and
the number of kids who were there and
like when we looked out at that audience
that day and you were addressing them
there had to be 90% of them were under
the age of 30
95 percent were probably African
American but they were listening to
everything you were saying
did you get I'm trying to understand
what you saw that they were looking at
you and getting what was it hope that
you
hey you you got out you made it you went
through this you know how I feel what do
you that all about that day I think it
was just all about devil
sizing me up uh first and foremost
because I was where they once were and
look at me dead in the eyes to see if
what I was saying was really genuine and
I'm not just standing up to be talking
because I've been where they were they
were about where they were at you know
this because you know I understand the
difficulties surrounding you know
imprisonment and I didn't I didn't ask
what I created that for myself and I had
to live it so you know I know how to
inspire those guys we all set around
this fight each other some days where we
all were crying and we all like you know
we do better so it was a you know this a
moment where I tried to embrace it and I
think they all did as well
were you a target in prison no
absolutely not no it was uh you know I
was just difficult just spending 23
hours a day not being able to do the
things that your customers doing not
having freedom so that's difficult for
everyone in here so can everybody was at
ease were you the best football player
in there yeah obviously oh well I don't
apply did you get to play quarterback or
did you say I don't want to play
quarterback I want to be running back or
I want to be a wide receiver over there
right over there and play oh you didn't
play football at all no we threw the
ball around one day what else buddy
oh yeah I go I mean I'm tired of
quarterback I want to play wide receiver
here man no no no it was a those dangers
Holly play would have been held in so
today
okay what are you going to do you want
to coach I don't know let's see um you
know I just want to create one day at a
time and not wrestling to anything in
terms of you know occupation but you
know I just been you know my near future
how computers yeah I hope so
and I still tell people that day in
Tampa that you did talk to these kids
but there were kids who were in lockdown
who must have done something they
weren't even allowed to be out in the
yard that day here and you went around
to every single one of those kids in
lockdown and it wasn't like it was on
camera and you spoke to them because I
walked around and I was watching and I
don't know what you were saying to them
but you did go around and talk to every
one of those kids so that that that day
had left a pretty strong mark on me as
well so I hope you can do it Mike I
would I could say to do good work and
good things trying to help as many
people as I can on my lifetime good to
talk to you Michael thank you and we
appreciate your time thanks Dan always a
pleasure
that's a Michael Vick now officially
retired at the age of 37
imagine him so much talent that you have
to take it easy or you feel bad about a
defensive player the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience